teachers in Arizona could be the next
group of educators to go on strike
thousands wore red and rallied outside
schools before classes yesterday they're
demanding a 20% raise in Oklahoma
teachers are on strike for the ninth day
today that state state ranks 49th in the
country for teacher pay Omar Villafranca
spoke to a former Oklahoma teacher who
moved to Texas for higher wages
he's at Louisville high school outside
Dallas Omar good morning good morning
the average teacher here in Texas makes
about fifty two thousand dollars a year
but if you cross over the Red River into
Oklahoma average teacher pay or it's
about forty five thousand and it's that
pay gap that's causing teachers from
Oklahoma and other states to relocate
and that's causing a teacher shortage
thousands of Arizona teachers joined the
call for higher wages Wednesday as
teacher strikes in Oklahoma over school
funding entered their second week
according to a 2015 study Oklahoma loses
about 13 percent of their teachers a
year to low pay many turned out of state
jobs over the last six years our teacher
shortage crisis has grown exponentially
Shawn Heim is executive director of the
Oklahoma State School Boards Association
our problem for decades has been we
haven't been able to retain teachers
because they could drive right across
the border it zoomed in on me let me
check that again math teacher Shaun
Sheehan was Oklahoma's 2016 Teacher of
the Year month after month we were in
the red this is with rent and daycare
before even groceries and diapers and so
we were living off of our credit cards
for the longest time how about last year
she and his wife Casey who teaches
English and their daughter Scarlett
relocated to Louisville Texas when you
crossed over the Red River into Texas
how much more were you making we my wife
and I as both educators immediately gave
ourselves about $38,000 $38,000 we
combined so two educators about 38 K
special education teacher Robin Edgerton
commutes 80 miles a day to her
out-of-state teaching job I think my
first year is over too
thousand dollar-a-year rings she lives
in Lake Havasu City Arizona and works in
needles California she says she'll never
teach in Arizona again no one cares in
Arizona those teachers care that's why
they're there if if Arizona would
support those teachers supporting those
kids their education system would change
100% Edgerton says she could not have
this same quality of life if she had not
changed where she works so does she hint
for the first time in my life I have
financial stability something I've never
known finally saving for my first home
it's it's it's remarkable Arizona
teachers could walk out as early as this
week and on Facebook live protesting
teachers were told by one of their
leaders to get ready to walk out of the
classroom and that quote the time is
coming John Omar thanks